[Music]
the day before thanksgiving we went to
my nana's house my dad's mom's house
and you know uh i'm not gonna get too
sad but i will say that
it was it was it was difficult
in in in one way particular because it
was the first time papa
wasn't there you know having passed away
um
months ago and with my uncle dan also
passing away right before that which
i've talked about on the show so it's
like there was this anticipation of okay
there's going to be some
some empty seats so to speak now i don't
it was
there was never a plan to leave seats
empty but actu
actually what happened what had happened
was
after our concert i've told you this
right
we we went to um well
at our concert at the north carolina
state fair
my mom and lewis rode there with my dad
and nancy so this is your parents and
their new partners
hanging out together yeah and nana all
wrote in dad's truck up there because
they were concerned about parking but it
has been
30 years or more more than that since
your parents were to
a couple so it's it's oh yeah it's we've
had a lot of time for the
for the awkwardness to settle a little
bit well but it's still
but it's still unusual they have never
ridden in the same car anywhere
right right right and so
when um when dad and nancy offered to
take them i was like okay i'll let them
know and then like
they did it and it went great and then
come to find out on the ride there the
ride back they're talking about
thanksgiving plans and how we're coming
into town for thanksgiving not christmas
time and they're like you know what dad
and nancy were like
sue you and lewis should come to our
thanksgiving
and i'm hearing about this and i'm like
after they had decided they were like
well we were invited i was like oh it's
i was like sounds weird but
awesome great okay make the rules
[Laughter]
so but hold on the first time ever my
mom
came to my dad's side of the to like a
a big family event on my dad's side of
the family but i will say because
for even birthday parties growing up i
mean they were all separate i'd have
twice many birthday parties
so many christmases what i'm getting at
is and you know
this is you know super common
in our in in modern society for families
to split up and there'd be
two entities and then the children have
to kind of make choices and go from
place to place right
it is pretty novel concept if you can
all get along
i mean get together it sounds it sounds
like a movie because it probably is
christmas eve we'd always go to nanny's
house my mom's mom my dad saw the family
i had nothing to do with it because
christmas night was nana's night for my
dad's side of the family my mom had
nothing to do with that
i was the only one that would do both
and it was great because i got
you know you end up getting a lot more
presence i think yeah definitely
um but now i don't really get much
presence and this is thanksgiving so
presents are out of the equation
oh your family doesn't do thanksgiving
presents huh no they don't
we don't we're not even thankful oh no
just kidding
so we don't even do things it was it was
this interesting dynamic and there's
like
i mean there's i think there were s what
was the number
it ended up being like 16 people there
so it wasn't like an awkwardly small
group of people sitting around a small
table
still a very we're putting a bunch of
tables together it was
it turned out to be you know it was
there were still moments of
it being very sad you know it's like
really
experiencing missing these key members
of our family for the first time so
i'm it it in no way
erases that but it created something new
i mean my cousin kurt and
they had an they had a newborn you know
three months old first time we met the
baby it was like
so there's all this excitement that like
gives
give something to celebrate you know
which was
um very much needed and then it's like
and then i look down at that end of the
table and it's like
my mom's sitting there it's like so
weird but
like this is great i mean i think
everybody's having a good time
and you know everybody did have a good
time
it all worked out and at one point you
know i've talked about
louis my my step-dad who i'll never call
my stepdad because
that's just weird because he got they
got married way after
i got married but i'm like his
catchphrase
good good good talked about that right
yes
we talked about we built it up but the
kids were like all right
papa lewis is gonna be at the
thanksgiving dinner tonight they're like
tonight
at nana's i'm like yes so let's do a
drinking game kids
every time he says good good good
you take a shot of gravy that's a good
idea
um and yeah i'm like silly you gotta
listen for it
and then lo and behold the kids get up
from the table after
like we're all sitting there at the
table after the food after everybody's
eating
some people start getting up they're
doing stuff but most people are still at
the table
and then i lewis was like oh boy that
was good
my ears perk up and i look over i look
across the table at christy he's like
pulling a cord
christy's eyes met mine and he was like
oh gosh that was good good good good
yes and then chris and i looked at each
other and that was like the best moment
of thanksgiving and then i look around
for the kids and they're not at the
table
they didn't even witness it i think lily
was at the table and she didn't hear it
somehow
and that was the only good good good of
the whole
you're kidding that's the only one he
did and he gave you like a a warning
shot
yeah i mean everybody could have
gathered around during that ball got it
i got it i just wanted the kids to get
it
i mean the next day which was
thanksgiving day we're at nanny's house
so my mom started family my dad and
nancy weren't invited to that i don't
know it didn't go both ways
i don't know what happened interesting
um and we're there and louis didn't give
a good good good there
it was good good bad bad bad
thanksgiving well
after it was great thanksgiving was
great there it was like manny and her
siblings uncle jimmy was there
never seen uncle jimmy yeah he was there
he's hard he's hard to understand
[Laughter]
i love the way he talks it's just i'm
just saying it needs to be subtitled
yeah it needs to be
he's like he needs to have his own
subtitle around his neck he needs to
have a reality he needs to have an ipad
that he wears
that's subtitled i'm not gonna do an
impersonation because
i don't i think that would be cruel but
it's uh it
i love him for it this is you gotta
that's the thing about getting together
with your family is just
yeah i'm in more observation mode you
know it's not like
we're getting into deep conversations or
anything we're just sitting around
nanny gets so cold that she set that
literally it was like 85 degrees
tropical and so like after after we've
eaten
and it's 85 degrees and you're sitting
shoulder to shoulder
in this like carpeted living room with
like the kerosene heater on
like everybody just started wilting man
and then a couple of family members
would have to go outside to smoke and
then they'd come back in and like me and
christy are really sensitive to the
smell of smoke and like
we got headaches from just the residual
smell on the clothes and
we started to really have a difficult
time so we had to
i was like well mom and lewis had to go
to lewis's family's thing and then we
were gonna stay
like two more hours i'm like after
another hour and the dog show's over and
stuff i'm like the dog show
we were wilting we had to like get out
of there so i'm like well
and we had seen nanny another day before
so we got some good quality time in and
then i was like
we said our goodbyes and headed out and
then we get out to the car and chris is
like well
we can't go back to brittany's because
they're not there they're at jb's
family's house and
we don't have a key so that we don't
have somewhere to be for like
two and a half hours i'm like well i
really need a coffee
and it's thanksgiving day and we're
driving around
to mcdonald's and then i get to
mcdonald's i'm like yes and then the
daggone mcdonald's is closed oh yeah
because you're in
and i look at crotch i look across i'm
in anger and then i look across the
street and there's a they got like a gas
station i can't get gas station coffees
and then we drive to fuquay i'm like
there's a mcdonald's in fuquay there's a
starbucks in fuquay
i go to both of those they're both
closed
i'm getting desperate i go to the dunkin
donuts closed
i'm starting to feel like a real loser
now i'm driving my family around on
thanksgiving day
just feeding for coffee and and
getting turned away like les mis well
okay that's a little uh okay i don't
remember the story les mis i didn't
watch the movie no it's exactly like
that
chrissy's like there's a sheets i'm like
gas station coffee oh [ __ ] you go to the
show
she is not a gas station you know what
she i you know what i have never been in
a sheets
i've never been inside of one what i've
heard about them
you can order food from the gas pump you
can order you can order
lattes from a screen inside which i did
of course you did and that explains why
on christmas day
me and my immediate family were playing
cards for
an hour and a half in a sheets gas
station
because we had no where to be
that's why we i got a group text of what
you were
uh you playing cards in a gas station on
thanksgiving
and you know i felt kind of defeated i'm
like
is this a father fail does this speak
does this does this answer the question
at the top of the show that like
it's better to not be with family on
thanksgiving because here i
am choosing to play cards just with my
kids and my wife
in a sheets gas station i mean and then
christy's like
you know what this could be a tradition
oh gosh
and it's a magical phrase no matter what
happens
if it's bad try this next time you're in
like a
a weird defeated or odd holiday
situation
just don't even think about it just say
it out loud speaking into the ether
this could be a tradition everything
changed at that moment
like i got a tingle of my spine i'm like
you know what the sheets tingle i got a
sheets tingle i'm like
yeah we can even if we're not
here for thanksgiving we can fly all the
way here to go to this sheet it's like
no we didn't mean that but
it changed the perspective on the whole
thing a sponsorship from sheetz would
definitely okay you'll work it
change this work it change it so that
that was my thanksgiving and by the way
then i left there and we met britain and
his family at a waffle house
so i went from a sheets and then spent
the next two and a half hours
at a waffle house on thanksgiving night
that's an upgrade
both places are great but waffle house
that's prime
i walked in we walked in the waffle
house and i
the manager looked at us
and he said out loud
basically at the top of his voice said
what the hell
and i thought it was like yeah
thanksgiving night i know
we're here at a waffle house course so
are you manager it's great that you're
here so that i can be here
and then it turned out at the end he was
a fan
but he didn't tell me that until that
was his reaction two and a half hours
later
so yeah gas station and a waffle house
on thanksgiving night
it can be a tradition to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best